hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and i'm
mobbin on through mob month March with
the Godfather to hated myself so as a
recap
I enjoyed Godfather realized that it's
just such an amazing movie it's
obviously as good as people say it is
but felt that it was probably a little
too long for my liking this movie was
increased by 20 minutes and so yeah it's
a little too long I'd saw that it was
three hours and 22 minutes and I went up
to the TV and took a photo with the time
stamp to express my upset it's such a
millennial thing to complain about I
think while being completely predictable
of me and my preferences I think that
this reaction video is going to work
quite a few film lovers and normal
people and everyone in between
everywhere so let's get into it huh
[Music]
you
was this amazing yes yes it was amazing
it was beautiful
incredibly well-executed very
intentionally paced actors are giving
the performances of a lifetime acting
their beautiful pristine little socks
off I don't know if their pristine I
don't know why that was adjectives I
chose to use pristine little socks off
just an incredible story and incredible
storytelling throughout some of the
scenes were just amazing did I like this
movie more than I liked Godfather Part 1
yes I did
I miss Vito but I just I loved Robert De
Niro as young Vito in this pretty much
made up for Marlon Brando not be in this
one I loved the back and forth
I left timeline jumps like that in film
and and this just did it masterfully it
really connected the two is I know that
it's part 1 and part 2 it's not
completely different films and it did a
really good job with that
obviously Thank You Tamara and 2019
telling us that Godfather 2 is well done
thank you but I just don't want to sit
through a three-hour and 22 minute movie
if it's not like your exact cup of tea
that's not even true it's not everyone's
exact cup of tea and they still love it
it's not in my wheelhouse of things that
I would choose to just throw up on the
TV and watch clearly nothing is because
this show exists and in that I think
that the three hour and 22 minute time
frame was just a little too daunting for
me to enjoy it completely I posited
quite a few times and got a stream
cheese came back and watched it for
another half-hour and paused it again
wouldn't played some Skyrim for a bit
came back positive again played our
organs for a couple of minutes
poorly positive came back again wish
that there was a horse you get the idea
I really enjoyed it in its excited
moments and in some of the more heavy
scenes the abortion scene yikes I just
sitting through a three-hour 22 minute
movie just it bums me out I'm starting
at one I am not getting done till for 22
two minutes I know people are gonna hate
this I know like every time I say
something about my opinion people look
like that's stupid and you're dumb for
thinking it well probably probably
you're right but the fact that I think
that Godfather Part 2 is too long and
Godfather Part 1 is too long I'm gonna
make some some fun enemies but that's
just it's just how I feel that's just
how I feel in this part two three hour
and 22 minute long experience it goes
through young Vito's life rising into
the Godfather position the DOM and then
Michael who has taken over after Vito
passed away in the godfather position
the done Michael is trying to legitimize
the family and in that does some really
shady non legitimate things
this is off his wife quite a bit Mike a
inspired look it's the only wig that's
kind of like in that era that I have but
I kind of love it
quick pull should I cut my hair like
this answer down below I'm not going
down there too
but I don't know someone
some of these scenes are incredible and
I think I would have personally enjoyed
it more if the movie wasn't so
long-winded in between these really
heavy and incredible scenes and exciting
scenes and and now that I'm thinking
back on some of these scenes I you know
I'm just getting stoked and pumped up
about them so clearly there's merit and
that you can have my answer now if you
like my offer is this nothing bitch it's
pretty obvious this is a gun wrapped in
a towel but somehow it still is pretty
menacing and scary so here you go
pew pew bitch for them you're nothing to
me now you know brother you know a
friend I don't want to know you what you
do I don't want to see you don't oh I
don't want you near the house when you
see our mother I want to know a day in
advance so I won't be there okay it
wasn't an abortion it wasn't a
miscarriage it was an abortion Michael
it was an abortion just like our
marriage bitch my father's name was
Antonio and Leaney and this is for you
Beach
oh my god this Apple is disgusting
Oh anything in the site that's certain
history as hot as anything it's that you
can kill any one bit cool Oh
oh my god how oldest is applo months
years old I have my own plans for the
future I'm going to the military thus
ending the film goodbye bitch some of
the character developments in this one
also really really good I think Hayes
arc in this movie is very interesting
I just loved their pure relationship and
I loved how she was trying to work
through what Michael was actually gonna
start doing for a living in the first
and then in this part really coming to
terms with it and and not sitting by and
allowing it to happen that one dude
Frankie sounds like he was the voice of
Watteau in Star Wars Episode one so that
was fun we have this senator who is
giving Michael so much crap and I just
in my notes wrote Oh horse head for
dinner mr. senator that confidence is
misplaced my friends it's really
interesting to see the similarities
between Michael and young Vito Robert De
Niro Robert De Niro is so goodness and
he's so handsome Michael why are the
drapes open in my house in my room where
my kids play with their horse bed listen
it's it's really good I think I would
have probably enjoyed it even more if I
was with like if I would have watched
this with Doug and Rob Walker and
Malcolm and Walter and I on Ann Heather
and I think if we were in a group I
would have really enjoyed watching this
movie and like talking about it while
it's happening but sitting here alone on
my couch for three hours and 22 minutes
it doesn't really do it for me I know
that's a personal flaw I know that
people aren't gonna love that but I
don't really care
go on now get I kind of just want a
90-minute thriller horror movie and then
I want to go play video games that is a
personal flaw on me and find whatever
sure in my house where my cats play I
don't even remember these I am so
thrilled that I have watched these
movies now it started off and I was
thrilled that I watched them just
because there's such a cultural
importance now I'm just thrilled I
watched them because halfway through I
didn't think I was gonna get through
them
so I'm glad it's done I'm glad I've done
it I would absolutely watch these again
but never alone I would never put this
on just casually but with friends I
would totally watch this again I am
excited to move on to Scarface I think
it's gonna be a little more exciting
maybe a little more up my alley
and I am going to try to do a live
reaction because I've heard the last
scene is pretty bad shit that shit
craisins I'm gonna try to do a live
reaction filming my reaction I know
people have been asking that from the
dawn of time with Tamra ever see and
then after Scarface all of next month is
gonna be cameo videos me and Doug Walter
Malcolm Brad Jones I'm gonna get a bunch
of people up in here the horse this guy
hasn't even Seabiscuit so you haven't
seen Seabiscuit crazy thank you so much
for watching my month has been very oh
it's the word I want to use I've learned
a lot really caught up on cultural
phenomenon and I think I'm in I'm in a
Goodfella camp and not a godfather camp
I know those aren't really comparable at
all but I'm gonna compare them
idiot thank you for watching I will see
you all next week with Scott face back
they made me an offer and I didn't
refuse it but I couldn't
[Music]
[Applause]
you